economía en francés 24 me acompaña en el
estudio jorge hurtado jorge comenzamos
hablando de la pandemia que aumentó la
informalidad en américa latina según la
oit así es un informe de la organización
internacional del trabajo detalla que en
el primer trimestre de este año el 76%
de los trabajadores y poco más de un
tercio de asalariados en la región eran
informales santiago el organismo señala
que persiste la desocupación y la baja
participación laboral en esta región a
pesar de que el producto interno bruto
de varios países están regresando
digamos a los niveles que tenía
prepandémica incluso afirma que la
recuperación del empleo no se dará sino
hasta 2024 o 2025 según los
investigadores a cargo de este estudio
solamente en 2020 se partieron 26
millones de empleos por el impacto de la
pandemia y una tercera parte de esa
cifra aún no se recupera
'jorge hablemos de ecuador que podría
recibir algunos recursos por parte del
fondo monetario internacional- ese país
llegó a un acuerdo preliminar con el
fondo monetario internacional para
recibir desembolsos de 1.500 millones de
dólares este año de un cupo que tiene de
6.500 millones de dólares 2 el año
pasado el ministerio de economía afirmó
que el siguiente paso será que el
directorio del fmi apruebe este acuerdo
lo que sucederá en las próximas semanas
y el país pueda acceder de inmediato a
un desembolso de los primeros 800
millones de dólares estos acuerdos
santiago se encontraban condicionados a
un plan de reformas de austeridad y anti
corrupción y ahora deben ser aprobados
por el directorio del fm y para entrar
en vigencia el fmi como sabrás e
impopular en la región por las estrictas
normas fiscales a las que somete a los
países en 2019 este tipo de acuerdo en
ecuador generó masivas protestas
hablemos ahora de la posibilidad de un
tlc bilateral entre la república
oriental del uruguay y el gigante
asiático china así es el presidente de
ese país de uruguay luis lacalle pou
anunció que la iniciativa para firmar un
tratado de libre comercio con la nación
asiática está en etapa de
prefactibilidad cuyo estudio finalizaría
este mismo año aunque con esto
contradice de alguna manera la postura
de mercosur de no permitir que los
países negocian acuerdos por fuera
veamos
con los socios el mercosur ha
manifestado su intención
de avanzar hacia el mundo pero al mismo
tiempo y se ha hecho explícitamente de
no ser posible
avanzar en conjunto que el uruguay lo
iba a intentar hacer si podemos avanzar
en conjunto mejor bueno santiago
mercosur ha tenido problemas para
entablar relaciones comerciales con
otros bloques por ejemplo con la unión
europea no se ha ratificado el acuerdo
negociado por más de dos décadas por
preocupaciones del bloque comunitario
sobre temas de tipo ambiental hablemos
ahora de los principales puntos de esa
reforma tributaria que aprobó el
congreso en colombia de qué se trata
bueno el senado y la cámara de
representantes aprobaron el proyecto de
reforma fiscal del gobierno la tercera
de esta administración el gobierno
espera recaudar unos cuatro mil millones
de dólares al elevar la tarifa
corporativa del impuesto de renta del 30
al 35 por ciento y hasta el 38 por
ciento al sector financiero según el
gobierno la reforma va a beneficiar
entre 12 y 15 millones de colombianos
con ayudas económicas para enfrentar
todos los estragos de la crisis que
generó la pandemia de coronavirus esta
reforma se aprueba luego de que la
iniciativa anterior desatará masivas
protestas que obligaron al gobierno de
iván duque a retirarla y a crear esta
nueva propuesta y para el cierre de la
cifra del día bueno vamos con la bueno
como indicadores de santiago si wall
street cerró en rojo por el temor de que
el aumento de contagios de kobe 19
limiten la reactivación económica
las bolsas europeas también cerraron a
la baja arrastrada por las caídas de
wall street y en américa latina la bolsa
de sao paulo registró una fuerte caída
de casi 4 por ciento en medio de la
agitación política que se vive en ese
país ahora si la cifra del día que
estaba esperando ahora sí ciento 187 mil
pesos ese fue el valor del dólar blue
este miércoles en argentina es decir el
del mercado informal que alcanzó su
máximo del año en este país funciona en
santiago alrededor de una decena de
tipos diferentes de dólar pero para
hacer una comparación el dólar se vende
hoy al público en el banco de la nación
a 103 pesos argentinos casi
que el informal el acceso a este dólar
oficial es muy restringido por las
autoridades muchas gracias jorge por
esta actualización del mundo de la
economía de nuestra región y también del
mundo es todo por el momento aquí en
france24 siga con nosotros buenas noches
[Música]